i want to bring you some breaking news
uh disappointing news if you're planning
a holiday
to croatia or indeed if you're in
croatia at the moment in the last
uh few minutes the government has
decided that
croatia along with austria and trinidad
and tobago
need to be removed from that list of
coronavirus travel corridors transport
secretary
grant shaps has tweeted in the last few
moments
that the data all points to the fact
that those countries
must be taken from the list to keep
infection rates
down if you arrive in the uk after 0-400
on saturday morning from these
destinations you will need to
self-isolate
for 14 days we know ministers met in
london
a little earlier on today to
decide on the fate of croatia and others
this is that tweet i was just telling
about from grant shaps
as you can see croatia austria and
trinidad
and tobago are all removed from that
list of
safe countries as it were quarantine
will be required if you return from
those countries you'll have to
uh self-isolate for 14 days follow
similar decisions of course
in recent weeks over spain france malta
as well it's uh bad news for many
holidaymakers emma birchley
is in the newsroom for us emma what more
can you tell us
this had been warned to keep an eye out
for changes
and those changes have now been
announced so
added to the list of countries where
travellers will have to go through 14
days of self-isolation on return
are croatia uh which had there had been
a lot of speculation about
austria trinidad and tobago now with
croatia
um we know that the world health
organization had said that they'd been
watching that closely since the
beginning of june
as the cases have been increasing and
certainly in the last few days that
increase has happened
at a greater rate the key number is 20
cases per hundred thousand and we
understand with croatia
that the figure was around 27 austria
two
as i mentioned trinizad and tobago now a
key thing though
is portugal portugal comes off the list
so that means that if you go on holiday
there you won't have to face
uh 14 days of self-isolation on your
return
and that will certainly come as very
good news to people who want to get over
there but also
to portugal itself who were very very
unhappy
when travel was allowed to many
countries but not portugal that was one
of the few places that was on the list
and a place which is hugely popular
with british tourists the thing is is if
you're trying to book a holiday at the
moment
it's an enormous gamble um you may look
at the r number try and find
uh the how many cases there are look at
news stories
but you're taking a risk and this
edition of croatia
austria trinidad trinidad and tobago to
the list
is proof of that just to remind you
france
spain are already on the list belgium
malta netherlands all of those places if
you travel to those
you have to face this 14 days of
quarantine
on return now the foreign office say
that they are
monitoring the international situation
it's under constant review
the health secretary said yesterday that
he's working
with heathrow and other airports to try
um to come up with maybe some way of
bypassing the quarantine so
looking at the possibility of maybe
testing
um the problem is is as we know
incubation in the body
um the virus may be there and not
showing up on testing so it's a it's a
tricky business
but certainly health secretary's saying
that he is working with airports to try
and find a way through this but
certainly if you're booking a holiday
you need to realise that it may well be
a bit of a gamble at the moment